so let's take stock of this for a moment
what have i got here um this is
promising this is uh this is progress
right you can see here that what i've
got is oh a plus a d which
is that original od vector that i
mentioned and then you've got this one
hanging out on the end so if you think
about this o a plus o a d rather
it takes me to um d as i mentioned
before and what i should get at the end
if this whole result is correct i should
end up at c right so i should be able to
go from here up to here this is the
remaining vector as it were
from d
up to c except i don't have dc there
i've got i
times a d which is there's a d and what
does i do right so this is where you
need to think back to your complex
number arithmetic and this by the way
overlaps with a bit of the exam review
we're going to do later on so sorry
spoilers this is something which you had
to do in your task if you remember
thinking about the parallelogram
question
you were given three vertices of a
parallelogram you had to find the fourth
one um the
mistake that a lot of students made is
what i'm about to highlight here so how
am i going to try and reason through
getting from this to something like dc
here's my reasoning okay
and i invite you to write this along
with me since i know that abcd is a
square that tells me there's all kinds
of relationships between the sides in
terms of ad and cd i know two things
number one the a d and c d are equal in
magnitude and i also know they're
perpendicular because all um you know
adjacent sides in a square are at 90
degrees or right angles right
so since that is true i can therefore
say that to get from you know if i take
vector uh a d and multiply it by i
i'm going to be rotating it
think about this for a second are we
rotating it by 90 degrees but make sure
you know which direction you're going to
be rotating it in right here is vector a
d so if you rotate it
by 90 degrees
anti-clockwise right so let me just draw
that in for you anti-clockwise
then you're going to get a vector like
say in this case it's it's vector a b
but vector a b
starting for a going to b is the same as
starting from d and going to c same
direction same magnitude so these two
vectors are equal to each other and one
of the common errors that was made when
you were doing this parallelogram
question in the in the 84 was that you
would say here mistakenly because you've
got these relationships here between the
sides where it doesn't matter like cd
and dc we think of synonymously but in
vectors they're not they are opposite to
each other right so that's why it's
really important that you make note of
the direction because that confused
several students
so therefore if i call this one up here
i'm going to substitute this
into one and hopefully you're following
along
and can see this pretty much gets us
home right
i can say that this
is going to be equal to o a
plus a d plus d
c so you just follow the tail to head
tail to head of the vectors you're
starting at o you're getting to a you're
getting further on to d and then you're
ending up at c so bc is by definition o
c which is
c as a complex number as required so um
i'll conclude like
such
alright so like i said this is not the
fastest solution i'm about to show you a
much faster one and then we're going to
move into reviewing the task but i hope
it was in a way that made sense for you
right that you can actually follow along
why i did every step that was kind of
even if you don't know what to do you
know how many solution methods like the
one i'm about to show you they require
like this magical insight you're like oh
it just came to me what i had an
epiphany and then i knew what to do
right this is kind of the way to slog
your way through when you have no idea
what to do with this result well write
it in vectors and then see where it goes
like expand um think about how to
connect this vector to this vector by
expanding you can it sort of falls out
even though it's not efficient
it works and it's not difficult to use
the knowledge there
okay okay as promised um and i'd i'd
love to know by the way if any of you
use the method that i just used or use
the method that i'm about to show you um
or a different way again right i
especially like it actually if you had a
completely different solution because
i'll i always love finding new solutions
basically
let me show you another way that's much
more efficient but blink and you'll miss
it that's how quick it is um and i
remember you know when i read this
solution i thought i would never have
thought of doing this
because i'm just not that clever maybe
some of you have um but you'll see why
i'm showing it to you second because it
it's a bit of a rabbit out of a hat
solution in my view anyway
okay what i'm gonna do is i'm going to
call you back to this line of working
that i had from the previous solution
right it's this reasoning that connects
a d and c d together namely
equal length magnitude
perpendicular so therefore i can get
from one to the other by rotating 90
degrees in the appropriate direction so
once you know this right you can
actually connect this straight to let me
just go back to the question right
here's the result we're trying to prove
this one right here right
if you look at it carefully you should
recognize that c and d and a the complex
numbers are closely connected to
o-c-o-d-o-a that's how i made this
direct sort of substitution here right
and if you have a look at this line of
reasoning you might recognize that c and
d and a all appear immediately like i
don't even need the origin really as a
reference point it's just kind of there
to help you right so if i think about
this line and um for reasons it'll
become clear in a second i'm going to
write it in reverse order so here's the
left hand side that i'm going to choose
and here's the right hand side
how can i turn this
you know what we did in the first
instance was we converted complex
numbers into vectors
c is the complex number is equivalent to
the vector oc right so i went from
complex numbers to vectors i'm about to
do the reverse it takes a bit more
thinking but it's going to pay off at
least i hope right dc how do you get
from d
to c which is this vector right from d
all the way up to c right
i hope that you can see one of the ways
you can do it is to kind of reverse
engineer this right so what i can do is
i can go from
d back to the origin right because i'm
going back to the origin this is not um
this is not
d lowercase the complex number this is
actually going to be
minus d right i'm going going the
opposite direction right and then i need
to go from there up to
c right so that's going to be little c
the complex number so
vector dc is equivalent in complex
numbers terms to
you do
d backwards and then you add c does that
make sense right can you see how i've
reasoned that and you can use exactly
the same logic to try and translate as
it were a d into from vector notation
into complex numbers so let's have a
quick look here um i was talking about a
d right so how do i get from a which is
here all the way up to d the answer is
start from the origin right uh so i
start from a rather
and go back towards the origin so that's
minus a and then move from the origin
just i'm pulling the same trick that i
did before and go up to capital d so
that's the complex number d so you can
see here this is going to be equal to
and hopefully you can see the parallel
with the other
vector that i've written there it's
going to be minus a plus
d right now from here there's almost no
more thinking this is the beauty of
complex numbers right arithmetic with
complex numbers equals geometry um do
you remember back when we first
discovered like multiplying complex
numbers together does like scaling and
rotation you're like whoa i just did
some multiplication and expanding and
collecting like terms and i got a whole
new number that just did geometry in the
background
this line is about to do all our
geometry for us remember what the result
is we're trying to prove we're trying to
make c the subject so i'm just going to
add that to both sides and then i sorry
i'm going to add d to both sides so that
i just have c by itself and then i'm
also going to expand this left right
hand side rather so i'm going to get
minus i a plus i d plus
d because that's the uh
that's where i got that from over there
okay and you're like oh
this is it like look at the result you
were trying to prove you just have to
factor out the the complex number d so
that leaves you with a one plus i does
that look familiar with the d and then
the minus i a i told you you would blink
uh and miss it if you didn't look
closely going from vectors to complex
numbers turns out to be like it makes
the arithmetic that's the whole point of
complex arithmetic it makes geometry
just come along for the ride